bon sang ne saurait mentir quand on a un
père excellent comédien que faire
d'autre sinon devenir soi-même une bonne
comédienne chez les trintignant qui sont
deux invités on pratique l'art de la
comédie de père en fille et c'est vrai
france roche en ce moment les
trintignant sont à la fiche sur
plusieurs fronts a mais la bande
trintignant frappe trois fois pendant
que nadine trintignant la mer termine le
montage d'une série télévisée avec
michel margueray jeanne moreau jean
louis qui tourne un film en présente un
autre qui s'appelle l'homme aux yeux
d'argent de pierre granier-deferre et
marie-jo au théâtre au café de la gare
nous allons parler tout de suite mais
france il faut parler de ce que fait la
fille marie trintignant cette fois c'est
du théâtre du corridor 10 café théâtre
mais c'est toujours de la police
seulement alors que le père est très
méchant avec son partenaire alain
souchon et bien marie trintignant à
l'aller très méchante avec le policier
policiers qui est joué par philippe
malaise dans les méthodes de camille
bourreau une comédie policière un peu
farfelue jean louis trintignant comment
voulez vous trouvez votre fille sublime
non je sais pas c'est vous dites un
jugement professionnel à l'événement
elle est magnifique je l'avais vu déjà
au théâtre parce qu'elle a déjà joué au
théâtre une pièce très dramatique de
dostoïevski et l'âge et les vues dans
une pièce comique elle est formidable
m'a vraiment étonné voulu donner des
conseils parfois au n'ont ils rien à
dire non mais quand même voulu aider
parfois non le mans quand elle a voulu
commencer être comédienne vous l'avez
encourager ou voulu avait dit tout ce
qu'on dit aux enfants quand on est
comédien assez difficile tu verras passe
d'abord tombak non je n'ai pas encore
âgé du tout je crois qu'il faut
décourager tous les gens qui veulent
être comédien mais ceux qui veulent
vraiment l'être le seront de toute façon
ne dépareille se décourager les gens
c'est vrai vous allez courage et marie
oui mais bon pas vraiment pas vraiment
nucléaire en fait vous avez toujours
voulu tu manqueras suède vétérinaire
puis après j'ai vu être courtisane
les annonces des deux c'était ça quand
est ce que ça vous à privas non
vers 16 ans et 17 ans alors votre père a
donné son avis tout à l'heure sur votre
prestation vous avez vu son film
j'imagine le moyeu d'argent les y
maintenant on dit tout ce que vous
pensez via vient en échange
c'est vrai j'aime bien aller dans les
rôles de méchants oui vous préférez
moi je j'ai écrit un sujet que je ferai
peut-être dans deux ou trois ans qui est
une histoire d'amour entre un homme
muret une jeune femme et je voudrais le
faire avec marie parce que c'est une
histoire d'amour qui n'aboutit pas à une
histoire d'amour qui pourrait aboutir et
qui n'aboutit pas et qu'est ce qu'elle
en dit elle ça n'a pas fait rire non au
nom
du fait des petits cadeaux
qu'est ce que vous aimez chez lui
à ce point ah oui oui je trouve que
c'est parce que dans la petite pièce en
tout cas d'un personnage qui est après
tout il est quand même possessif il est
très présent presque trop présent pour
une fille non
bah ils sont heureux ensemble y sont il
devient il devient et devient généreux
après
c'est celle pas que doivent faire tous
les parents pour arriver à lâcher leurs
enfants alors nous un peu vieux pour ça
on est important mais c'est tout le
chemin qu'on a à faire
pour accepter de voir ses enfants
recensant soit avec avec d'autres qu'est
ce que vous aimez chez eux
pour boisset marie c'est celle à
merveille jamais rien eu avec elle de
qui marchait pas depuis qu'elle est
toute petite depuis qu'elle est née
même je crois que petite elle a jamais
pleuré je sais pas je ne me souviens pas
que qu'elle ait été un moment un
problème souci elle a été que du bonheur
tout le temps et c'est pour ça que non
seulement vous jouer cette pièce comme
édition à quai de gare mais vous avez
aussi des poèmes à lou si vous êtes
décidé de travailler maintenant toujours
tous les deux ont peut-être pas toujours
mais oui c'est vrai que la dernière fois
qu'on était au théâtre c'était il ya un
an et demi en juin saad il ya une phrase
qui a été qui a été coupée d'ailleurs
dans la pièce mais qui qui résume assez
bien un rapport jeudi un moment secret
va élever des filles pour qu'à 30 ans
elle vous lcl vous quitte avec le
premier mec venue
alors c'est beaucoup vous allez me dire
là si c'est vrai ou pas vous tous et je
voyais juste avant le journal vous tous
et vous détestez vivre à paris parce que
c'est polluer vous êtes un petit peu
misanthrope
non vous vivez à du pur trouvera pas du
tout non j'aime bien les gens non non
j'aime beaucoup les gens contrat je suis
très curieux non les gens me plaît
m'intéresse beaucoup alors comme je suis
très timide je peux pas leur parler mais
j'aimerais beaucoup
vous êtes 38 votre timidité à votre
fille et pourtant vous faites du théâtre
c'est toujours quelque chose qui me
surprend surtout vous là dans cette
pièce acometis cette capacité de dire
les choses avec légèreté mais avec d'une
totale un pilote tout compte fait sur
existe de théâtre comment vous basculez
de là un autre sur une scène de théâtre
on a vraiment une sensation de liberté
on al'excuse que c'est pas nouveau ces
panneaux phrase c'est des phrases qui
ont été écrites et la sensation personne
ne nous arrêtera donc ça donne une
espèce de de liberté pour les timides
sait on peut insulter les
insultes et la vie les gens et être en
même temps ils responsables et sincère
sur le moment scène et puis le fait de
pet arrêté non j'aime beaucoup
ça va pas de facile pour patrick lisala
de travailler entre vous deux je
souhaite rentrer vous deux vous laisser
un peu d'espacé à quelqu'un d'autre vous
qu'on leur mette dans la vie en vous
relations patrick c'est une merveilleuse
un garçon formidable non même beaucoup
je pense qu'il est heureux avec nous non
je pense qu'il est heureux mais vous
n'êtes pas l'impression vous formez
tellement un duo y compris dans la vie
que c'est de pas très évident de de
rentrer dans votre univers où il est
gentil doux c'est un peu l'histoire de
la pièce alors bon on est dans une
situation merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'être venu
[Musique]